[Music]
this is the danger this is the danger
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
you live in right now but you're not you
might not be alive tomorrow it's a very
serious issue fun and games
playing that Xbox all day or chasing
that man or woman partying all the time
and you forgetting about the reality so
many distractions so many distractions
and you forget about death the reality
of it forget about paradise what we
should have our hearts attached to and
you forget about the Hellfire it's real
I'm going to be talking about how's your
n going to be are you preparing for it
or you just hypnotize mesmerize by the
delights and the fantasies of this world
all this and more with Sheikh Abu Toba
here on the Deen show and we also got a
special guest was going to pop in sit
tight don't go nowhere we'll be right
back this is the Dean the Dean Jews
[Music]
you know this is the things is the
danger this is the dangers of the danger
[Music]
this is the things that angel
[Music]
this is a Salam aleikum walekum Salam on
a hotel a replica - peace be with you
and the mercy of God Almighty Allah and
you know what
this topic a lot of times you know you
think religion is kind of like in this
society is taboo some people you know
something personal between me and God
but these are real issues death is a
real issue Aslam is something beautiful
it's logical and it's the
fastest-growing way of life in the world
today it has the proofs and truth that
is indeed a divine system a way of life
from the Creator and it's based on
knowledge that you come to it and you
examine all this a book that's been
unchanged the Quran and we can go on and
on we cover so many topics and it just
gets you constantly to reflect about
what we're going to be talking about the
end tells you what the purpose of life
is and to prepare for the end paradise
or the Hellfire to their judgement now
before I open up this topic I just want
to tell you a real story that enticed me
to do this program you know we know some
of the youth they get caught up and
tantalized and into this lifestyle
Facebook texting all day talk woman
talking to the man the man chasing the
girl young kids and getting pregnant and
going to these parties sneaking out and
that's exactly what happened some of
these youth there was a story in the one
of the Chicago newspapers of a group of
kids two boys and I had four girls in
the back they snuck out most of them
they went to a party so two three in the
morning happens around that time they
get in an accident the parents who are
thinking that the kids are in bed
sleeping now they get awoke to the phone
call that their child is in a coma ones
actually dead others in critical
condition so it's sad to say that's even
after this some don't wake up some you
get their attention and now they're
listening but then again the lifestyle
overtakes them the bad company and now
they're like Tupac and $0.50 you know
when they got shut up and they're like
feel untouchable you know so they got
bragging rights right right right so we
really want them to reflect so we can
talk about this issue the seriousness of
death and
doing righteousness living a righteous
life so you don't get caught off guard
and then the angel of death snatches
your soul and you end up in the Hellfire
what an awful destination awful place to
be what are your thoughts on the ship
I'm delighted up a lot I mean when I was
listening to you here two things came to
my mind allah says in the quran qaloo
neve sin that i could melt every soul
will taste death everybody is going to
die one day and that's a reality this
reality and a lot of young people
believe that not me not yet because I'm
young not me not yet all right we think
it's something far away it's only for
old people or somebody else or it has to
be and you know sadly you know when I
hear something happening over in other
countries they believe oh it's we're in
America we're in the West where in
Europe we're safe as though death
doesn't come in these places and the
other thing when you mentioned the
purpose of life you know Michael up
through general insane deli Abba do you
know that except to worship Me
Allah tells us the purpose of life is to
be the slave of Allah to slave for Allah
so that's what what I do it I know I
said say well that's what I do that's
what I thought about when you said that
you know that the interesting drill that
we were taught was the the you know the
magining yourself dead you know that was
the the famous drill that paint the
picture now paint the picture you said
picture yourself dead so you know give
us a visual you okay so right now
imagine just your name you know who you
are
Eddie mullah Sabu Toba you know John
Garey whatever you know Dennis I
Muhammad Ali regime Ayub you know Yunus
any one of the people that you don't
imagine yourself dead right now
we're at your funeral we're at your
janaza okay you're laying there just lay
down right now put your hands over
yourself you know and later and think
for a few moments now just do this with
your imagination and imagine now your
book is now closed and ever
body is walking away from your grave
what are they saying
even if you don't care what they're
saying what does that book read what do
you want if someone was to summarize
your life and say what you what did
Eddie stand for you know what did he
leave behind where were you you know
that that is a very you know tremendous
you know understanding that you have to
gather get at the out of that point you
know you have to try to understand this
was my whole life I'm not promised
tomorrow what did I leave behind and
another interesting thing we were riding
in the car over here you know when you
were playing that there audio it
reminded me that when you die the thing
that you die doing is the thing that
you're resurrected doing and sometimes
we hear that and we don't understand in
what context that means that means if
you died and you are at the club dancing
when you wake up you're machi Amma
you're going to be dancing and you're
going to continue to dance you can't not
going to be able to stop dancing now
they say look I like to dance I'm being
resurrected on what I'd like to do they
don't rise there is no sir you can be
naked uncircumcised dancing and going
dancing over to your your your your your
coal your hits add to your record being
reading so when you get cold before
allah subhanho wa taala you're going to
be doing that particular D at that time
uncontrollably and it's like
self-evident of what you are all about
it's going to display what you were but
again the mentality is not there for
young people because they think that's
cute sometimes they think that is funny
they don't realize that you know life is
a gift and that it can be very short we
only live in like 80 something years now
that's not a lesson to make it to 80
years right I mean that's that's the the
average longest of my heard from what
imam that you know there it's not
they're not bearing more old people
they're bearing more young people yeah
that's the thing nowadays you know the
thing you know I I remember you know
growing up in New York City you know to
be old was you know very difficult there
was a lot of you know to make it to 20
make it to 21
you ROG yeah you know I I had a list of
friends that I you know we used to keep
about 31 dead or in jail doing life in
prison for killing somebody or for doing
some stupidness like that and after that
we stopped counting
so people that younger people are they
should be feeling happy that they don't
have that type of violence in their
lives that causes that type of death but
they're doing things their own selves to
oppress their own Souls and you know
really the solution is Islam but some
people think that I gotta get right to
get with this lab but that doesn't make
sense you got to get with Islam to get
right you know and they think that it's
something that's not cool there is
nothing cool except for Islam
otherwise you're foolish because you
can't make decisions as based on wisdom
and knowledge except that allah subhanaw
taala gives you that wisdom and
knowledge and not only the best wisdom
and knowledge is in the quran is in the
sunnah of the prophet salaallah so
anybody wants to be cool then they
should practice islam it is the coolest
thing you look fly i look fly we you
know the way what other religion can it
be that you grow a beard and that's part
of your Deen everybody knows the guys
with the beards look good whatever
religion you wear your clothes your bag
they looking nice on you you know you
have wise they're covered up nobody
knows what your lady looks like you have
many children
you name the names of the best people
who ever lived the names of the prophets
if they're men the names of the Sahaba
yachts and the other famous women where
if they're if they're women you know and
not that you restrict it just to those
names I mean this is the best Dean you
know that you can have you can have more
than one wife whatever religion allows
you to have that everything else is you
know you have this dis crazy stuck like
you don't drink wine it makes you sick
anyway you know you don't get drunk and
get high because it makes you lose your
mind go into those closets and that loud
loud Mose you can't say you enjoy that
you wake up with a headache you wake up
sick at the end of you still feel empty
empty and that's what this is Salaam
gives you it gives you that sense of
peace through submission through setting
you know surrendering
give it up giving up giving up and we
want everybody to give up and that's to
the one who created you and we right
back with more
Dean shows too tight can't see what
everyone's talking about heaven a shadow
Allah and 11 he loves but the argument
here is that God out of his love because
in all honesty if you really wanted to
do something you're gonna find the way
when there's a will there's a way
absolutely there are a few problems here
why were people of generations and
generations and generations being told
to worship one God asked that God for
forgiveness ask him for for salvation
seek His mercy no one else's so he
picked up the Quran which is the last
and final Testament the lasting final
revelation early sixteen years eight
years in active reservist and eight
years act will do but the bottom line is
that I'm an ophthalmologist I'm a
specialist in cataract and refractive
surgery on a medical director of the
major I say these are not God God is the
one who created everything in his
universe that's the one I'm going to
worship and prostrate to how can you go
wrong doing that
don't believe it I'm yours out of this
long and I mean top 10 reasons why Jesus
cannot be God let's get right to it not
be God number 10 number 10 back here on
the Dean show and we're talking about
how is your end going to be are you
going to be resurrected are you going to
be brought back up dancing with a
holding a 40-ounce holding a whiskey
bottle or you know what you're going to
be resurrected in sejoon in prostration
in saying labbayk allahumma labbayk
doing good knees doing goodness and
that's what we want to encourage people
to really reflect about this now we
talked about the story of the youth it's
a real story and there's so many more
where deaf that's something that we
think is far away it just as may be in
the show is over you know you you walk
across the street or you have a heart
attack just like that and we'll take it
from here
the woman we're listening to that story
she actually went to Hajj the fifth
pillar of Islam and then she got enticed
and then went to the party she went to
the wedding if you continue on with the
story how did I go well there was a
Lebanese woman the Lebanese woman and
not that I race makes a difference but
just to help understand the culture yeah
young lady she went and made Hajj you
know she was out there going to the
clubs in partying and then she said you
know what I want to be a HUD gem this
has a high position in Islamic world you
know and so she went made her Hajj she
came back from Hajj I said I'm clean my
life up now not and I'm a Hodja I'm not
going to go to parties I'm not going to
go to clubs I'm gonna read Quran and
everything but she's still a young lady
in her young 20s and around that time so
then her friends are getting married
some of her friends and they said look I
know you're hydrogen now but just come
to the party you know the things that we
have in our culture sometimes they
totally come to the the party if the
wedding is lawful but the party that
they have with the dancing with the men
mixing with the females and his type of
things she knew what was there and she
said initially she said no I'm not going
to go you know i Mahajan I have a
reputation I have the honor of being a
Hodja I don't want to go to this part
but you know again the bad companionship
they kept you know come on one time one
time you know back in the days go for
for the good old times so she came to
the party she came to the party not
initially thinking that she was going to
get involved in the things that were
going on at the party okay
just to come to show her respect so will
people say all the time then her
favorite song came on the song that she
was known oh that's your song girl and
they started to encourage her get out
just you know just dances you know you
know how you used to do it she got up to
dance and she had a heart attack she got
up to dance to one last time and that
was her one last time I was one last
time finish and she had a heart attack
and she died at that and you know a lot
of times we see people at the kaabah
they're making dua they're saying and
you know if you sit there at the Kaaba
up close people are saying things like
you know what if I if I if I go back to
that those types of deeds cause me to
die just take my soul of love if I if I
go back and do those sins again you hear
them saying that you know at the get the
gate at the door where your dua are
accepted when they're hanging on to the
Kaaba and maybe I when I heard about
this lady
I said maybe she was one of those people
that we saw at the Kaaba asking Allah
not to let them do sins again and take
their soul and everything like that but
sometimes people take this as a joke and
think that okay I said that but I didn't
really mean it and maybe that ladies do
I was answered and then at that moment
she she passed away you know we have a
lot of things that the young people are
involved in I'm sorry no no Kay I want
to just add time is short we got so many
points we want to cover tell us so what
we learned from this is that
companionship but now the thing is how
do you because the Satanic forces are
working so many people want to change
they see this lifestyle shallow it's
hallowed there's no you know there's
some fun but it's it's like eating that
that that sweet strawberry it's poison
inside and you're poisoning yourself
you're getting those black stains on
your heart but now you're switching over
we know a sister she wears hijab she's
changing you know she's listening but
then yeah you know the the righteous
people turn the corner she's on the
Facebook she's texting well she cannot
leave those elements the lifestyle that
have such
a strong impact and she's more fearful
about what they're going to say how
they're going to view me and good luck
mentality look is that what how do you
eliminate yourself from that there's a
big you know there's another you know
evil companionship we're talking about
nowadays you shouldn't be worried about
the click see the thing about it is on
the last day when you you know when I
said imagine yourself dead what I'm
saying is imagine now for yourself your
book being read if you think someone is
bad and you talk bad about him then you
get his bad deeds if you don't give if
you give them as good your good deeds or
you don't have any good deeds to give
them you're going to take his bad deeds
if you worry about what people are
saying you know then this is real now
even if they're not listening to your
watching you but if you think they're
listening to you and watching you and so
you react because of that then you've
done an act because of them because you
see them not because they see you and
again this is real
a type of shirk the bottom line is that
people should remember two things their
purpose of life is that they want to
impress Allah that's it
impress alum and that doesn't mean you
can't be cool in oppressing Allah Allah
made the life easy for us okay and gave
us everything that we could do to be
easy if you don't know they got it ask
the people that do know so they can help
you find a cool way on Islamic way to do
it and you have to remember that you
will stand before law you're going to
die you're going to die all of a sudden
it's not sudden there's no no letter in
the mail no letter saying on this day is
coming this hours no it's going to
happen all of a sudden so you know you
have to be careful about what you're
doing because the deeds are summed up by
the last of them so the more you know
now now that person is hearing this and
now it's different if that person didn't
hear this or didn't get the truth
delivered to but if they hear this now
they're more accountable is that right
yes your account about in Islam
ignorance of the law is an excuse but
then again there is criminal negligence
and then once you do know you expect
that's what the balance is you know our
optimist 14 is the balance between those
who did know like the Jews they know
better but they choose not to do they
choose to do what they want to do and
the Christians who don't know necessary
but they try to do things without any
knowledge the Muslim is between those
two extremes
we're not extremists you know we don't
do what we don't know and we do what we
do know so we stop where our knowledge
you know ends and but we work to the
extent of what we know
so we're held accountable for those
things that we know a few more a few
more points now the Facebook and a lot
of these other media outlets which
obviously there can be a lot of good
done from you I invite people to the
truth on it you can you know what I
didn't see the girls shouldn't put their
face on the Facebook what do you think
now you know you got these young women
also and they're exposing themselves and
about their striking a pose and you know
chatting with and it's different for
guys you know we got a guy if a guy put
his face on the Facebook there's no harm
the man's face is not you know it is not
so beautiful we're not there handsome or
anything like that but a woman her whole
thing is out up even her face yes a
woman's face enhance could be but what
type of person is looking at this
Facebook you don't know you have the
perverts and the straight people and
someone's sitting here drooling over you
how many times will be seeing Justin in
the in the Craigslist those ladies the
guy was looking at these ladies on
Craigslist then following them up and
raping them okay following them up and
killing them five murders or something
like that happened on the Craigslist
then they had to change the whole way
they do it because people are you
putting your advertising yourself no
this is not love for the ladies to do
this stuff even with the niqab their
eyes look so beautiful
the out there and and the niqab looks is
just as bad as without them to calm you
know and what is the purpose again the
intention of putting your face on this
this thing it's not a an outlet for you
to try to get married through that way
okay you know yeah it should be some
shyness you don't throw your whole self
out in front of the whole world so the
whole life has revolved around getting
the attention pleasing your creator and
not the people in this clique or people
from this lifestyle that are going to
clubs and you know following JLo and
Britney Spears you want to follow the
way of the best example Altima all the
profits and the last and final messenger
sent to mankind and this is how you
could be successful you know the only
success you know the only success
through following the Quran Allah says
in the Quran cut off l'homme noon
meaning the believers have become
successful every time we say in the
Adhan haya ala sola hiya allen fella
come to success the success you know men
whoever or you tailor what a salut you
know whoever is already obeying Allah
and obey his master
he's called affairs a thousand a demon
he has already achieved the highest
aspiration he could possibly hope to
achieve there is no real success in the
dunya or the hereafter without following
the way of the prophets alive Salaam yes
okay and I promise that we have a
surprise guest oh yeah yeah he's going
to be on a second tell us now we you
know we're optimistic people I mean when
people talk about death a lot of times
people make a joke they'll change the
topic because it gets a little
depressing but we're optimistic that
look we're going to do the best that we
can and we got paradise we got paradise
God willing that's what we're striving
for so it's a it's a it's a call for
people to race for not just the the
lights of this world but for the
delights of paradise and the only way
you can do that obviously is by pleasing
your Lord and doing righteous deeds
right well you know the life doesn't end
us again our reality is different in
this life we know that death doesn't end
our existence
it just takes us from one existence to
another existence that's what that's
what we have to realize you know that
our life in this world ends but our life
in the hereafter in the next war even in
a grave our life doesn't end you know
we're still doing things and have
another existence that we're going
through where there you go alright go
quite like a salon without the like hey
are you doing all tired I just have to
stop in there just a mic they're talking
here yeah sorry well what honest is guys
here me salon or everybody like who
Salam hey hey man
Ibrahim
okay and he's telling me that we're
almost out of time but tell us I heard
that three things follow you to the
grave and you can't take all of them can
I take all my toys and my card money
what we're going to the grave Oh Kayla
hamdullah that's very very important
question
Ibrahim the important thing to recognize
is that when you pass away the further
your good deeds your bad deeds your
deeds are going to follow you to the
grave okay you're any good deed that you
taught somebody some knowledge that you
gave somebody the humdinger that's going
to follow you okay
some sadaqa some charity that you did
ongoing charity that's going to follow
you and if you have a child a child a
righteous child okay you married uh any
sisters out there you know I wanna get
Mary a handle on when I don't know yeah
okay well we'll try to get you a wife or
something like that
insha'Allah insha'Allah Allah then if
you have a righteous child a girl a boy
they make dua for you you know that's
the thing you can benefit your deceased
your loved ones once they pass away by
making do offer them and also by doing
charity for them
like if you give charity for yourself
you can give charity for your deceased
relative as well okay you know okay
thank you next time maybe I'll come back
thank you for having me on oh can you
put your dream home and you've got your
dream car but you're gonna get old and
things going to happen to you in your
life and then what have you got at the
end of the day is an empty dream that
has no real foundation we are gonna die
and we're gonna meet our Lord and he is
going to judge us it becomes an
obligation for each single human being
to find out what the Quran is Islam is
telling us to stay away from things
which are bad for your person and bad
for the society
[Music]
it's killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious hey alright I'm
gonna lie Abraham well that was our
special guest and thank you for being
our guest yeah oh my God Almighty Allah
rewards you I mean thank you for the
great advice medical ethical we are
thank you and that is it for this
episode of the Deen show how is your end
going to be all that partying all of
those good times and then what you
forgot to reflect you forgot to prepare
just like that person that examination
you didn't study then what you don't
pass and this is the ultimate test that
we have to pass the test of life living
life how the crater wants us to live
doing his will not our desires chasing
that boy that girl outside of marriage
Facebook all day listen to Lady Gaga
Lady googoo 50-cents Britney Spears all
that other nonsense has taken your mind
away and you're not reflecting about the
purpose of life the seriousness of life
and that is what we're here for trying
to have you think about these serious
matters how is your end going to be when
you fall in the gray when you get put in
the grave and the dirts in your mouth
and is done you can't go back you can't
go back not even to say a good word and
and all you're doing now is saying curse
words Islam is inviting you to something
that's so beautiful to establish a
relationship with the one who created
you and to do righteous good deeds to do
righteous act good action so you can
develop yourself to be the best human
being that you can be continue to tune
in next time for another episode of the
Deen show until then peace be unto you